[Music]  my name is mike tobin i've been at fox  news for 20 years you know i got into  this business because i wanted the  action my job is chaos and there's  plenty on the supply side i could  ballpark some of the winds if maybe 70.  i want to get out on the front lines of  the biggest thing that is happening i  want to rope it in and get it to the  viewers  when i went to iraq my instructions were  just go there cover it see what they see  experience what they experienced good  bad ugly and bring it home  jumping out of helicopters with the  paratroopers  hold this position those are real  bullets  i'd be dumb if i wasn't scared sometimes  i just always hoped that i was bringing  a little bit of comfort to the families  if they saw the report saw their loved  one or saw a guy who knew their loved  one they knew that they were okay  at least for that moment of time